in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and with me now
in the studio is Maria reshit resilience
trainer facilitator coach and consultant
hello and welcome to in good shape all
right thank you if you look at two
different persons one is very high
resilient and the other one has a pruitt
resilience how do they behave in life
well you could look at it maybe an
extreme situation for an example like
say someone lost their job they got
fired a person with lower resilience
might go straight to the bar and drink
to excess till they just forgot what
happened a person with higher resilience
might go for a walk connect with their
physical body maybe with nature and then
also especially find a supportive friend
or someone that they could talk to about
what happened and how they felt about it
and the sort of the resilient extra edge
is to look at what's the opportunity of
the situation is it the opportunity for
a better job or maybe to start the
business they've been dreaming about and
that's part of where resilience adds is
looking how can I create from what I
have so if life hands you a lemon try to
make some lemonade exactly has it but is
it a choice I can do with free will it's
um it's a habit and some people have it
less developed than other people also
people have it to different degrees in
different parts of their life and it is
possible to develop your ear resilience
that's the great thing of the recent
research in neuroscience neural pathways
build up by the things that we do over
and over again this whole
use-it-or-lose-it principle and the
brain grows and changes so if you're
developing new habits of making
resilient choices and resilient
responses to situation that's going to
grow in your brain and can overtake the
old ones so how do I actually grow those
habits do I need to wait for crisis to
appear to try to solve it or can I train
this over normal course
life yeah it's actually better if you
start thinking about resilience and
practicing it before the crisis because
then you're prepared for the crises it's
hardest to develop resilience in the
middle of a crisis so that's in our work
we do workshops and trainings to help
people look at what's going on in their
lives and how can you make different
choices and so a key part of developing
resilience is just becoming aware how do
I respond to my stresses and challenges
and then what are my options what do I
want to choose instead of maybe you know
reaching for junk food instead of going
for a walk and it is it really worth it
all the training and trying to change
the habits is it worth it or is it
resilience dangerous for your body for
instance do you get hypertension if you
have poor resilience no resilience is
there's no evidence that it indicates
it's dangerous what it does is it's
really focused on bringing you back to a
centered peaceful calm state kind of
like that bamboo we were talking about
yeah right and so it improves the immune
system by having more positive thoughts
more optimistic outlook your immune
system gets stronger those researcher
white cells can get stronger so you're
able to fight off disease and less
likely to get sick right so and if i
want to start to become a very resilient
person tomorrow what are the first steps
for me to take the probably the biggest
first step is to just start practicing
gratitude am writing down or sharing
with someone three things that you're
grateful for every day is a great place
to start and then to look at your day
and at the end of the day maybe or when
you have a chance look at what's the
best resilient response i had to a
challenge today and what's the worst
resilient response like say that you're
with your partner at the start of the
day and you help them get ready for a
big meeting and and that felt really
good and then later in the day you're in
a conversation with your boss and it was
uncomfortable and didn't really work
reflecting upon your best in your worst
resilience and look what can i bring
from my best resilience activity into
when i'm in these situations with my
boss or difficult conversations and so
looking at how you can apply the egg
resilience you already have to new
situations this is a very conscious
approach so i have to try to to learn
from my mistakes the one with the
gratitude is it's more supple isn't it
yeah the gratitude
is more subtle and easier even Oprah
raves about the power of that practice
really yeah and is it because you just
have all the back full of all those nice
thoughts with you which you could use as
a resource in the next crisis or is it
that really the brain changes because of
the point you view your life they go
hand in hand as you have that bag and
you're familiar with it the awareness of
them and then your practice of them
increases your ability to use them in
the likelihood that you'll remember them
there's also physical things that you
can do to in the moment to increase your
resilient with that there are two ones
that we recommend highest our rhythmic
breathing which is at the simplest it's
breathing in and out for the same count
like in one two three four 1234 and
doing that for 42 minutes will change
the pattern of your heart rate and bring
you calmer and make you smarter you're
giving more access to your thoughts
another one is the power poses so these
are different positions that research
has found own that like when you're in a
sitting situation like this and if it's
appropriate you put your feet up on the
chair and two minutes like this will
reduce your cortisol rate measurably and
increase your testosterone road and so
it's making you more calm peaceful and
ready for whatever comes never H a lot
of things you can do to increase quality
of life thanks so much for being with us
in good shape thank you thank you
you
you